so it's Friday and that means it's time
for another movie review now we're
actually doing a recent one that's right
it's another arty movie I love arms
warts never you know you guys heard me
do a review of Conan there's a lot of
are any movies that I like and I like
Arnie for Arnie but this is a pretty
interesting film cuz he he goes Indian
this he goes in D and small budget and I
was impressed with it for what it is I
was as well I have to say I wasn't all
that except like when you first told me
about it I was kind of like okay maybe
we'll see how that goes but it actually
turned out like way way better than I
expected
it's very different from an old art it's
very different very different but it was
it's kind of like a pleasant surprise
he's getting older he's not really
believable in an action role anymore
yeah I mean he's probably in his what
come he's about 70 yeah he's gotta be
what Arnie's get what what his gimmick
was is he was kind of like your uncle
who showed up to your house and you're
like uncle Arnie Oh Barney put the bear
suit on because the bastard on the hardy
sounds and you know I love that and he
was cast that way when I went to see an
Arnold Schwarzenegger movie that's what
I was expecting to see yeah even all the
way up into the 2000s what was it six
day I really like six day they came out
that was a good movie I think it came
out in 2000 and he was still that same
Arnold Schwarzenegger superhero type
character you know like like Quaid from
Total Recall normally that's the way he
is but this one he actually proves it he
can act yeah
he can act which like I said this was
kind of amazing yeah and in fact this
movie everything about this movie is
kind of amazing yeah um it actually was
released in 2015 it got a limited
theatrical release and also came out on
VOD this at the same time it's an
independent movie yeah it's a first time
director and a first-time screenwriter
right they got Arnold [ __ ]
Schwarzenegger to be in their movie yeah
those dudes right brought you want to be
in our movie they believe it and like I
said we have it on blu-ray yeah
blue-red I'm glad I did because they had
a lot of extras and it's it's a good
watch
I mean it's we're not talking about a
huge budget Arnold Schwarzenegger
over-the-top movie that's not you know
that that was another era this is only
think it was one point four million
dollars one point two million dollar
something like it was under two million
yeah which is nothing for a movie today
that's nothing and very limited
theatrical release I think it made a
couple hundred thousand dollars on
theatrical release so you know then it
went directly to blu-ray and streaming
and I look young I've done the same day
that it came out in the theater but
basically and you know um it seems to
have made about four million dollars
yeah
which that's good on a million point for
invest yeah and you know I Arnie got to
show people that he could act and on the
back of this I went ahead and bought
aftermath with that that's his one that
just came out yeah and I think it's a
2017 so I'm you know I'm trying to get
up-to-date on my arm sports negra game
yeah you know you like this kind of the
pent gang yeah there's some of the stuff
that I've missed from the 2000s but I'm
gonna go back and get some of that you
know and I hadn't seen rowdy in a long
time but I'm just trying to appreciate
Arnold while Arnold is still with us and
now to be 70 it's time for him to show
what he can do he can act he talks about
it and the coolest thing about this okay
like I said this kind of like gives me
hope for my own work yeah the director
of this is named Henry Hobson he's
actually a Brit he was a graphic
designer he's only 34 years old and he
actually started out in the biz he went
to the same arts college as Ridley Scott
because Ridley Scott was like his idol
yeah so he wanted to do a similar thing
for the past 15 years or so he's
actually been working as as I said a
visual artist a graphic designer
he does the titles for movies I think he
did Sherlock Holmes and a few other ones
he's done a couple of commercials but
he'd never done a movie before can't
really tell Kenya you can't no it's
amazing well and one thing that he did
do and I think Arnold Schwarzenegger
mentioned this on some of the extras
on the movie was that he had drawn like
200 I want to say 200 pages of
storyboards showing how he wanted all
the shots to look and everything like
that like he what they were really
really super detailed Arnold said he
thought was fair but like he really
admired that I also want to say too that
the screenwriter who's named John Scott
3 this screenplay for Maggie was it
actually won a screenwriting award like
in some international contests or
something and since it won that it's
kind of been making the rounds in
Hollywood because I guess in Hollywood
they have something called a blacklist
which it sounds like a bad thing but
it's actually a really good thing
because it's kind of the list of
screenplays that are that are really
good that are circulating around
Hollywood but haven't been made yet they
like they haven't landed at the right
studio or whatever yeah Arnie saw this
one and he's goes I want to make this
movie yes
so this script has kind of been
circulating a lot and a lot of people
were interested in it right and actually
I believe that our old Schwarzenegger
approached them later first whoever had
the descriptive rights according to the
interviews and yeah and they were kind
of blown away and he said that he wanted
to do it he want to do our movie he's
like yeah and Arnie said he already said
the director was great and that he'd
worked with him again any time and I
like the I like that all these British
guys are coming here to show and
Hollywood how to do [ __ ] yeah because
Hollywood can't make a movie everybody
knows that now and and Hollywood actors
can't act the best American actors right
now are actually British people they can
you would never know like on The Walking
Dead well that those are not southerners
and we're southerners we know what
southerners sound like the sound and act
just like southerners they got it down
Andy Lincoln fooled me yeah well because
I know like after I started watching The
Walking Dead I realized that he had been
in love actually yeah but that's a chick
flick so I've never seen it because I
don't like chick flicks so I didn't know
that he was British I only found out
that he was British like when we were in
the middle of season five or something
but I nearly [ __ ] myself I couldn't
believe it how they would sing with
Maggie Hollywood nowadays they can make
a superhero movie I'm gonna give them
that they can make it big they can make
a big budget like spectacle tell you
though robot punch and dinosaurs they
can do that [ __ ] but
they do believable characters and not
anymore and they can't ride around they
can't really write about bravery and
heroism anymore Hollywood movies tend to
be cheap shots then this movie here
though it feels like a good quality
movie it feels bigger than it is but
then when you get to the ending of the
movie you realize that you know what it
that was a small budget movie yeah yeah
no I mean but it was still a good
experience watching it and it was a good
experience seeing Arnold Schwarzenegger
act I could not believe it because
here's the thing I like Arnold
Schwarzenegger 'he's 80s action movies
and things like that what they know as
much as anyone else I'd be commando
right Marv doubt that damn genre but you
have to admit that Arnold Schwarzenegger
is like a caricature he's like a
superhero exactly he's not like a dude
he's not like her about person oh that's
your uncle in the Bears right that's
what I mean he's bigger than life bigger
than life it's like in pretty much every
movie he's like that yes so the thing
that I thought was super cool about this
movie was that I'm not gonna say that
you forgot that it was Arnold
Schwarzenegger cause she you know that
I'm not gonna go that far right but the
fact that he was willing to step up and
go you know I just want to play in every
man type character well there's no you
know not really any heroism not really
any bigger than life he's just a guy and
he lives on a farm and it's just trying
to protect his daughter and he can't
yeah and it's just seeing him act like a
regular person like so restrained and
everything was like really I was really
impressed in case in case you guys don't
know and we didn't mention it this is a
zombie apocalypse movie but it's kind of
a believable Zambia pockets not like oh
everyone here is like diseased they're
not mowing down babies there it isn't an
action movie it's basically a plague has
really kinda gone through the population
it takes a long time to turn to a zombie
doctors are involved law enforcement is
involved when you start getting a little
too zombified they ask you to go into
quarantine yeah they take you away
basically they end up killing you they
euthanize you
pretty much they have to because you
start biting people yeah and you start
eating animals and even trying to eat
people right but it's a slow process and
when you watch the movie it's pretty
cool you find out that you know Maggie's
still able to stay home even though
she's partially zombified she hangs out
with her friends and you know does
things that American teens do out in the
country you know like going to the
Riverside and campfires and drinking and
some of her friends have the zombie yeah
what I was like a boyfriend that she
dated yeah and they're talking about
that they have it it takes a know
they're gonna die it takes it can take
weeks or months to actually turn uh it's
it's an interesting play oh yes zombie
apocalypse theme to me it feels like a
pretty well done con a slow-paced
two-part episode of The Walking Dead
it is I would call it I wouldn't even
call it a horror movie there's some draw
in it but not much but I would call it
like maybe a zombie drama drama the
movies kind of a downer in a certain way
it is very sad it's a very sad sad movie
it's taking there's no electricity where
Arnold and is on Arnold's formal call of
our remember within the character's name
Wade Wade that's right there's no power
there but there's power in other places
yeah it's not like it's not like a
hellscape no no it looks like the Dust
Bowl yeah it's like stuffs been
disrupted obviously and there's you know
electricity is patchy and things but
where his family lives is kind of out in
the middle of no like out in the Midwest
where I don't think they specify where
it is but you know they don't have
electricity out there but it's implied
that other places do I mean there's
still TV there still yeah cops keep
showing up because they know that
Maggie's got it they keep showing up
checking on her and kind of pastor and
Wade they're like man look she's getting
ready to flip man you got you're gonna
have to take a quarantine he's like give
me more time you know you just have to
see it when you see it I don't want to
spoil it yeah I really don't want to
spoil the movie you can watch it I think
streaming right on Amazon Amazon has it
I think they have it for rent for $2.99
yeah and I've seen it for sale on
blu-ray
recommend the blu-ray because that's
what we have yeah it's it's a very nice
movie to watch and I think it's
realizable even though it's yeah watch
it every year um like I said if you're
an Arnold Schwarzenegger fan and you
like his action movies and stuff like
that I'm not sure I don't like these
action movies I like to recommend it if
that's all you like because this yes
he's in it yeah but he doesn't play
there is nothing of the Arnold
Schwarzenegger you really know in it I'm
gonna say if you like Arnold
Schwarzenegger movies if you like his
action movies and you want to see more
of Arnold you want to see Arnold today
and you're kind of a completist
you will probably enjoy this movie I
want to see everything that he that he
did yeah but like I said I mean this is
this is my kind of movie because I'm
more into I like slow paced movies I
like Atmospheric seventies atmosphere
this yeah this is a very it's it's very
atmospheric it's very slow-paced the
director actually said that he was
trying to get the look of American like
Dust Bowl yeah type photos they didn't
want ease and stuff so that's so the
palette is very muted there's a lot of
like long shots of like people's faces
new very sad so you know you can see
where he was going with that it's very
Midwest there's like these big sweeper
offices of like wheat fields and stuff
but it's just very gray yeah and it's a
very like I said it's a very sad movie
but the best thing about it and I think
that the director Henry Hobson said
something about this too that when
Arnold Schwarzenegger approached him
like being interested in the role he was
like he found that idea very intriguing
because he's like the whole theme of
this movie a relationship between the
father and the daughter and the father
being unable to protect his daughter as
badly as he wants to and he's like and I
really liked you know that there was
this shorthand I mean urlshortener
Gracie's big guy he's a big action here
and he's still pretty big even though
he's 70 yes not a little guys like so I
liked the idea of putting this guy in
the movie and it's like as big as he was
as big an action hero as he is all this
baggage that comes with him
works to the movies advantage yeah
because he's made vulnerable by the fact
that there's nothing he can do to help
his daughter she got bit and like and I
was gonna say to that this isn't like a
classic zombie where your bit you die
and then you come back from the dead
yeah these people are technically still
alive so it's more like a 28 days later
situation where you get bitten it's it's
more like a virus yeah then an actual
cut we're coming back either guys turn
black to get black and they it's like
cannibalistic and then they turn
cannibalistic and then they have to be
euthanized to you know for the safety of
the public so you know so it's not like
a classic zombie it's more like like I
said like a 28 days letter type
situation where it's treated more like a
pandemic it's you can rent it for
probably around three dollars but you
can also buy this on blu-ray on eBay I
think I got my flex six dollars
delivered it was well worth it
yeah it was well what did like I like it
yeah you know I'm a completist I like to
have everything you know I'm gonna try
to maybe make a make my version of an
Arnold Schwarzenegger blu-ray connection
eventually you know but I saw it and I
liked it I also bought almost watch
there's a new one
aftermath yeah I think I paid $8
delivered for that one on blu-ray now my
friend Matt he's also enormous for
tonight huge Arnold Schwarzenegger it's
a huge action move huge he's much
younger than we are yes younger than
yeah he's like my adopted son he's like
30 he's like I've already met Duke could
throw so many bullets a second minute
sounds like little throw so many punches
per second sounds like he loves all that
stuff and he's a little he's a little
badass okay
he saw Maggie he liked it he recommended
it to me he got it he rented aftermath
and while he's watching that he's texted
me he's like he's like this is a very
different kind of movie this isn't like
a movie it's like it's like you're
watching reality and I said are you
enjoying it he goes it's weird man oh
man oh hey goes yeah you got a later on
it's like you got to see this I didn't
really enjoy it man this movie disturbed
me but I do respect it so now I'm really
interested on what the hell out or mad
yeah that movie this movie I mean I'm
not gonna lie they're Downers they're
Downers and I think that that's not I
don't mind
that actually well I like down here
that's kind of what I was picking up and
what Matt was telling me about this
movie in aftermath is that from what I
can gather of aftermath
Armel is kind of like a psycho stalker
in it anyway because he doesn't usually
play bad guys now matt said man I got
the feeling that what Arnie's doing is
that you know he's retired he doesn't
have to make these movies to make money
right he's got shipped tons of money
he's married into the Kennedys Arnie
really when you really look at Arnie
Arnie was an Austrian soldier that
immigrated into the United States and
basically became royalty he was the
governor yeah California he doesn't need
to make these old movies but what Matt
said Matt had the feeling that Arnie
knows that he's 70 now he's not gonna be
with us forever
so now's the time he's gonna make these
movies to show everybody what he could
have done like his legacy his legacy
which like I said I mean mad props to
the dude yeah and as much as I enjoy his
action movies and you know I dimensional
right today are very one-dimensional
character sees he's a comic actor kind
of is an action star yeah although I'm
gonna kind of kind of kind of amend
slightly what I said there are a couple
of action movies that he did that are
just head and shoulders above predator
is one of the per I love predator it's
an action movie but it's also horror
movie and it's a sci-fi movie and it's a
military drama that was an excellent
movie Conan the first in lots of
symbolism lots of you know to mean
warrior virtue you bought him bought him
as in Conan won Arnold is taking me to
Samaria yeah you know I'm buying it he
doesn't talk much he's acting mostly
just with his face facial expressions
and body language you know but I really
love but that was John Milius you know
John Milius he can write and he could
direct it yes so given the proper
material even in an action movie
Arnie can kick ass even something is
kind of crazy as Total Recall that was a
mindfuck because really when you watched
her a recall Quaid's back at recall he's
he'd never got his ass to Mars
you didn't go to Mars
all right he was back he was yeah when
you're a young man you're buying into
yeah yeah he really is the secret agent
on Mars find an alien artifacts and yeah
he really did get the girl no he's back
at recall they told him that he would
boolean this 100%
I don't want to get on to a recall right
now we're on okay just gonna give it
give a good recommendation for this
movie if you go on right you know Rotten
Tomatoes you know it's a very mixed
reviews but don't believe those people
because you don't know the age fans want
action yeah I feel like that's kind of
the problem it's like you know and
welcome to the basement which like I
said that's not like they need a plug
cuz that's right but this is my favorite
YouTube show one day this they actually
they didn't do a whole show review on it
but somebody asked them what they
thought about it in their little scenic
segment and they both actually really
liked good taste
yeah and they said that they thought the
same thing that I thought when you first
hear about it you think oh it's
quote-unquote stunt casting you out yet
but in a way like it works yeah like I
said when the screenwriter wrote it when
the director directed it
they weren't picturing Arnie in that
role right but when they heard that he
was interested that possibility
intrigued them because they're like the
whole point of this movie is that here's
a dad that knows that his daughter is
gonna die knows that she has to go to
course he knows that she's gonna become
dangerous to his wife and his other
children and yet he still can't let go
of her well you know back in the day in
another era for Arnie the money was in
those big action flicks where he's uncle
Arnie he's and he's in the damn bear
suit he's gonna give the audience what
they want now he can sit back like an
acht or you know talking about yeah and
do some weird art flicks but yeah and
he's gonna like that and he's gonna
leave this behind in his legacy yes it I
gave you guys what you want back then
can't really do that at 70 so much show
you some cool [ __ ] before I'm out yeah
and I have to tell you
and this full disclosure at the end of
this movie no the one scene I'm gonna
say about this one scene where he's
downstairs and he's pretending to be
asleep with the shotgun across his lap
and Maggie who the progression of the
zombie disease is kind of like
intermittent yeah so most of the time
she's normal but she kind of starts
looking worse it's all over sometime
then sometimes it gets a hold of her and
she can't control herself like so one of
the best scenes is that he pretends to
be asleep he's down in the living room
and he's you know got the shotgun across
he's like you in case he has to shoot
her yeah and then there's this thing
where she kind of comes down and she's
like smelling him because that's one
thing that yes once the disease
progresses the sick people start to
smell humans as though they are food
right and then they don't like real food
they want to reject and then they yeah
they just want to eat people so this
whole scene where she's just like
getting closer and closer to him and
you're not sure what's gonna happen and
he's still pretending like he's asleep
with the gun he's like oh man yeah is to
get a shooter is he yeah it's like that
scene was like really really compelling
and I have to say too I did kind I
didn't cry cry yeah but it's my eyes did
tear up at this movie it's a very very
sad movie it's very sad because you know
what's gonna happen to her and she knows
yeah it's kind of a bummer movie but
it's still a good movie a lot of good
movies survive and I have to give a
shout out to to Abigail Breslin who yay
Maggie did a great job she's cute too
the funny thing is that originally Chloe
grace Moretz was actually interested in
doing this movie and she would have been
good too I loved her in the letter Let
The Right One In
Let Me In remake she was very good in
that she was actually slated to be in
this but then she had a scheduling
conflict and she had to drop out so they
got abigail breslin who actually she
[ __ ] man she won an Oscar when she was
little for a little miss sunshine which
was actually a really good movie she's
also in another movie a horror movie
called Haunter which I'm not sure if
it's on Netflix anymore I saw it on
Netflix a couple months ago and it's
actually really good it's kind of a
weird premise it's like kind of a
time-loop ghost story type of thing but
she was in that tube so I'm gonna
recommend that if you want to watch that
but she was really believable in this
because she's like a teenager yeah but
there's kind of like like I said it
almost didn't have to be zombies it
could have been just a movie about a
family and the daughter has a contagious
disease right and the family kind of
falling apart as a result of that like
she knows she's going to die she's
dangerous to the other children and also
I liked that they made it that Maggie
was Arnold Schwarzenegger's his
character's name is Wade is Wade's
daughter yeah but is actually his new
wife like her mother has died yes
remarried yes she's got a stepmom yes so
her stepmother yeah don't don't spoil
any of that right so there's like this
whole dynamic really like she has to go
to quarantine and the other kids and
blah blah so it's like there's that
going on too when you got when you guys
go watch it just make sure to look at it
in a certain way you're not you're not
talking about an Arnold Schwarzenegger
blockbuster that's now what this is this
is a small yeah dark indie film set in
the zombie apocalypse but it's not
action it's more like psycho drama drama
yeah it's very emo it is so like if you
like a lot of the more dramatic and it
looks really good which shines yeah of
like Walking Dead don't they don't
expect flipping busses and explosions
and guys mowing down ceases Abbie's
that's not what this is this is more
kind of like a grisly old farmer in the
middle of the Dust Bowl just trying to
survive this damn plague and his
daughter is falling prey to this plague
and people are trying to take her away
kill her yeah what does he do you know
yeah you'll see but like I said it's you
know it's actually a really good movie I
know it has mixed reviews it's a female
it's what film yeah but I actually
really liked it good yeah and I have to
say that I was really impressed by
Arnold Schwarzenegger yeah he could have
been actually acting that given the
right now I got aftermath coming in a
couple of days and I'll probably either
update on half
after math and if it's good enough we'll
talk about aftermath also some of these
old classic actors from our generation
you know like I said they don't have a
lot of time left so let's put on oh yeah
and if they're doing good
let's spotlight that while they're here
and I should say that on some of the
extras on the blu-ray for Maggie Arnold
Schwarzenegger I think that he got
interested in this role mainly because
he had you know he has kids of his own
so now that he's older and had kids that
age or he could remember what it was
like to have daughters that age yeah he
that really informed his performance
right and like I said I totally bought
it it was very very sad and the
chemistry between the two of them was
really good I thought yeah I mean I like
Abigail Breslin she is cute as a button
I loved her in Haunter she was really
good in that and her and Arnie had like
a really good repair with each other it
seemed it really did seem like fun one
of the things that I think is going on
the reason why our knee is 70 years old
and he's still trying to bring it is
because there has been there has been
kind of a traditional rivalry between
Arnold Schwarzenegger and Sylvester
Stallone yeah of course okay they're two
American alpha males well I got an
Austrian you know and actually that
whole Austrian Anka Varney really is
what made Arnie Arnie didn't have that
accent he would have never been the
superstar really but hey that was part
of his deal but Arnie and sly have
always kind of been rivals yeah but they
like each other they respect each other
yeah they're like fun rival right not
always but they are now they're older
than they were now but Sylvester
Stallone is another old guy whose movies
are kicking ass well they are kicking
ass right now he's writing them and
producing them same kind of thing
limited theatrical roles this way and
raise audiences the thing about
Sylvester Stallone is that he kind of
got a jump on this because he could a
keen Copland yeah which [ __ ] I remember
how long ago I saw that in the theater
that must have been back in the 92
thousands and I was actually impressed
back then I'm like yeah okay that's a
good idea
all right well actually I think so I
could always act even go back to Rocky
yeah he could always act because he
could ad-lib and he always looked very
natural Copland
was Sylvester Stallone's Clint
Eastwood's
oh yeah okay I gotcha Maggie is kinda
like Arnold Schwarzenegger 'he's
Unforgiven that's kind of like a good
way to pet you know there's so many like
quote unquote action stars from the 80s
yeah and then later on when they try to
do other kind of movies right oh wow
they really can't act but sylvester
stallone when Copland came out people
like holy [ __ ] he actually can act
although he was in he can always act he
could always think it always act yeah so
but Arnold Schwarzenegger this was kind
of like that for me where I was just
like holy crap he really liked not in
the sense that I thought that he
couldn't act before but I didn't know if
he could be someone the other then you
know if he had the range right like I
was like he's very good at being Arnold
hmm I was like can he just be a nobody
can he just be a guy and I didn't think
he could until I saw Maggie yeah and
then I was like I totally bought that I
totally bought that he was just this
Midwestern farmer who had a daughter
that was turning into a zombie and he
didn't know what to do about it
and it was like it was amazing I saw a
little little of this in in the last
stand cuz I had that one too yeah
there's a little bit of this action also
in escape plan one where he was in there
was supposed to Stallone you haven't
seen that one yet
yeah but already actually kind of
actually he's going crazy and screaming
out in German and everything so he's
been slowly building up to this but this
is his Unforgiven you know if you if you
guys have seen that movie lacking the
action of course but dramatically yeah
this like I said this is a drama not an
action movie I don't even think I would
call it a horror movie it's got a couple
kind of gory scenes in it but it's not
really hard
not really a horror movie either no I'm
really looking forward to see aftermath
because yeah because Matt said it was
disturbing he doesn't really want to see
it again so I'm gonna go you know I bet
it's like a recommendation yeah yeah
yeah Matt's kind of conventional you
know I mean he likes action movies and
spy movies and [ __ ] like that you know
because yeah yeah I respect that movie
that really disturbing man I don't think
I'm gonna watch out here we'll see the
minute somebody says to me it's like I
don't wanna watch that again it was too
much of a bummer it was soon as I'm like
yeah that's on my list now I mean you
see that yeah he's just trying to show
me what he can do that's good and like I
said that is super cool and you have to
respect somebody for wanting to do that
he doesn't need the money anymore man
you can just be in whatever you can see
Becca do nothing and like I said the
coolest thing about this movie goddamn
first time director first time
screenwriter yeah and look at like the
star power they got to be in it
you know it's [ __ ] that's amazing yeah
and I don't know they didn't spend any
money on it not really like I said less
than two million dollars and you don't
need theatrical releases anymore you can
stream it and go right to blu-ray and
still turn a decent profit I think yeah
like I said that gives me you know
nearly 4 million nearly if somebody ever
wanted to like take one of my stories
and turn it into a movie that would be
really rad I think that I actually might
happen eventually I'm like I'm older
than the director of this movie which is
kind of bummed it's the technologies out
there and there's a lot of talent out
there that needs to replace these old
dinosaurs sitting up there you know and
Hollywood Charlie what's crumbling it's
falling apart
and rightly so it's now spreading out
everywhere talented new guys coming a
lot of emerges from other places inside
the english-speaking world even have
some Indian guys doing this kind of
stuff and eventually we've actually seen
some really good Indian movies yeah yeah
good good South Korean movies train to
Busan oh my god that movement was so
good gotta get that on blu-ray so good
it might oh yeah another zombie flick so
if you want a zombie if you want a
zombie flick that's like a zombie flavor
as much as I'm just getting killed
meeting people and train like a
fast-paced oh yeah and trade was so good
train to Busan is on Netflix you if you
have Netflix you can yeah it was I just
checked ok so it's on there yeah that's
a good movie alright so we're done
talking about zombie movies for the day
I guess go see Maggie if you haven't
seen it if you're
arnold schwarzenegger fan if your zombie
movie fan like i said it's kind of its
kind of a drama not really a horror
movie not a ginardi uh normally yeah
it's it's kind of a bummer yeah but if
you're into that like I am then you
should definitely go check out
atmospheric you can stand up with a 70's
type atmosphere in horror movies yeah it
kind of yeah and remember if you like
the show to like share subscribe and
share on all your social media it really
helps us out a lot if you would like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page at patreon.com slash
thirteen o'clock or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress comm and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account or you can
give a one-time donation and either
thing is much appreciated also if you
are on our patreon if you're one of our
patrons who gives twenty dollars or more
a month today I am sending out some
little care packages and other stuff
their autograph posters - yeah they're
kind of like a grab bag this month we
did kind of like little posters that we
signed I did book stickers it was just
stuff that I had around the house some
of them are my books some of them are
other people's books some of our
magazines some one from her you know
it's just a bunch of fun stuff that I
like so everybody will get something
different this time around so I'm
sending them out today so keep a lookout
for those and the stuff that we gave you
kind of matches up with who you are we
know who you are I hope so I tried I
really did but that will do it for this
latest movie review make sure to check
out our regular episodes every Tuesday
and our movie reviews every Friday and
that'll do it for this installment see
you next time bye